لو ندخل اكتر بالتفاصيل معا متفسرين هاي
المفارقه بين اتهام المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وغيرها من دول اوبك بلس بتسيس الطاقه في
الوقت الذي طلب فيه بايظ نفسه من الرياض
ارجاء اي قرار بخفض الانتاج لمده شهر كما
تردد
الانتاج لمده شهر حتى تمر الانتخابات
النصفيه في الولايات المتحده تاكد رجل
الامريكيين والمهتمين ان جو بايد لا يملك
سياسه للطاقه ولكنه يملك رؤيه سياسيه
لكيفيه اداره الانتخابات وفي الحقيقه فان
لهذا اثار المدمر على الولايات المتحده
انه رئيس للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكان
يتعين عليه ان يقدمه المصالح الامه كلها
على مصالح الحزبه او مصالحه الانتخابيه
والسياسيه الضيقه عبر تعزيز الرؤى
الاستراتيجيه طويله امل وذلك من خلال
تقويه حلفائنا والحفاظ على المصالحهم وصدي
اعدائنا وما نراه في الشرق الاوسط هو عكس
ذلك تماما
على التمييز بين اعدائنا وحلفائنا
واصدقائنا فهو بصدد التمكين للجمهوريه
اسلاميه الايرانيه منذ اليوم الاول في
المنصب وذلك بتاكيده انه يرغب في احياء
الاتفاق النووي غير المتوازن وفي الوقت
نفسه اعلن منذ اليوم الاول انه سيستفض ضد
دول هي حليفه التاريخيه كل هذه الكوارث
سواء على صعيد السياسه الخارجيه او
الداخليه او على صعيد اداره ملف الطاقه هي
بصدر تدمير صناعه الطاقه الامريكيه كل هذه
الاخطاء الخطيره والكارثيه التي جرى
ارتكبها يدفع الامريكيون ثمنها وليس مسؤول
عنها اي طرف اخر باستثناء جو بيض وحزبه